and keeping in the vein of you know
optimism and believing there's a higher
good you have a message I believe that
you've said that if someone is estranged
from their parents that they should
while they're still alive make attempts
to reconcile that you feel that that's
very important absolutely I I don't know
if I would be sitting here today had it
not been for the discovery of that
storage locker imagine what are the odds
of finding all of this personal
information about your parent including
60 hours of contemporaneous audio
Diaries starting from before you were
born right up until the ton that parent
who you were struck with whom you were
estranged commits suicide and it gave me
an extraordinary opportunity to meet my
father before he became my father as
well as after and to meet him as a man
rather than as a two-dimensional
authoritarian figure that I remember
from childhood so it allowed me this
unprecedented opportunity to reconcile
and to make peace with with my my father
and it was such an extraordinary and
unusual situation that it certainly made
me grow spiritually to to a great extent
but to your point knowing how rare this
opportunity is I go around telling
people whether they want to hear it or
not if you have an issue with either one
of your parents make peace with them
while you can because you won't find a
storage locker filled with audiotape
like I did
you